-Also, I should mention my holiday single
is released today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's called "Almost Too Early for Christmas."
-Almost.
-It's "Almost Too Early for Christmas."
Me and -- The great Dolly Parton helped me out
and made the song actually listenable.
It's fantastic. She's great.
And I just want to say thank you to Dolly
and thank you to everyone out there
who's given me some love on this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's almost -- It's too early for Christmas, this song,
but it could be used to get in the spirit.
And everyone wants to get in the spirit, everyone wants to get happy.
You plan for the holidays, Thanksgiving, or whatever.
And I was thinking -- this would be great if this could happen.
I would love this song to be the on-hold waiting music
for the Butterball Hotline.
[ Laughter ]
So, if anyone out there knows anyone at Butterball...
-Let's get this done.
-It's been my dream since I was a child.
[ Laughter ]
-To get your song on the hold music at the Butterball Hotline?
That's been your dream since a child.
-Yeah, I was a little child, and I would just dream about --
-How old? How old was this child period?
-Probably like... -29, 30?
-30-year-old child, and I go, "I want to be the hold music
for the Butterball Hotline."
-Right. -'Cause everyone's calling.
They want to know how to make their food or whatever.
Any tips you want, you call the Butterball Hotline.
And I would just -- I was --
If you can -- A kid can dream.
-Right. That's what you want for Christmas.
-I was that little -- I was that little Butterball.
-Aww.
-They used to call me Butterball Boy.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
Butterball, if you're listening, I'd appreciate it.